auf der Bahnstrecke zwischen Bonn und
Köln sind die Arbeiten an der neuen
S-Bahnlinie 13 in vollem Gange im Jahr
2028s oder Plan soll es eine
Direktverbindung zum Flughafen geben
doch jetzt stellen die Verantwortlichen
fest das kann nicht klappen den in
Troisdorf kommt die S-Bahn auf den
linken Gleisen an müsste aber um
überhaupt zum Flughafen zu kommen auf
die Rechten Gleise wechseln das
funktioniert aber nur mit einer Brücke
irgendwie wurde die wohl vergessen
wie so viele Dinge die geplant werden
und vergessen werden für ein paar
Millionen und wir die wir täglich fahren
und pendeln müssen müssen dann drunter
leiden das die Brücke nicht eingeplant
war ist im Grunde nicht zu verstehen
also es sind ja letztendlich Fachleute
es ist ein Schildbürgerstreich aber mir
ist mittlerweile das Lachen vergangen
nach jahrzehntelanger Planung beginnen
2016 die Bauarbeiten für eine
Direktverbindung von Bonn zum Köln
Bonner Flughafen Kosten 750 Millionen
Euro kurz nach Baubeginn ist klar am
Bahnhof troisdorf ist auf der viel
befahrenen Strecke kein Platz für die
neue S-Bahn um dort per weiche die
Gleise zu wechseln ein sogenanntes
überwachungsbauwerk müsste her dafür
gibt es aber keine fertige Planung
Kommunalpolitiker Ingo Steiner weist
seit langem auf das drohende Schnellbahn
Fiasko hin im Grunde hätte man
eigentlich zuerst das
Überwerfungsbauwerk planen müssen bei
der S13 weil das einer der
wesentlichsten Bestandteile ist und
nachgelagert die anderen Maß zusammen
aber das ist jetzt zum Schluss kommt ist
natürlich noch mal ärgerlich weil das
verzögert die Sachen noch erheblich bei
der Stadt Bonn und dem Rhein-Sieg-Kreis
sieht man die Deutsche Bahn in der
Pflicht deren Planung sei in einem
rudimentären Stadium die Bahn dagegen
weist alle Schuld von sich seit die DB
2020 den Planungsauftrag erhalten hat
und die Finanzierung geklärt ist
arbeitet das Planungsteam auf Hochtouren
um die Brücke schnellstmöglich zu bauen
niemand will dafür verantwortlich sein
dass jahrelang nichts passiert ist also
ich muss sagen das ist eine absolute
Fehlplanung mal wieder und ich finde es
eigentlich eines Skandal es ist einfach
unfassbar also ich weiß gar nicht was
man dazu sagen soll genau weil auf der
Arbeit würde sowas auch nicht passieren
bzw hätte das da ordentlich Konsequenzen
soll es jetzt zwei Krisen Treffen geben
dann will die Bahn eine Planung
vorstellen wann das Brückenbauwerk
endlich gebaut wird kann momentan
niemand sagt